[music]
>> I mean
what a lot of a lot of
a lot of
a lot of a lot of
a lot of a lot of a lot of a lot of
Islamic greetings as-salamu alaykum
warahmatullah barakatuh.
And I hope
you had a good refreshing
tea break.
And I'm seeing that some of the
participants
little bit feeling
not very fully attentive. I know that
you're not used to
sitting here for 8 hours and listening.
It's a part of training inshallah.
First two days I do excuse.
Third day I will not excuse. Fine? It's
a training you just a little
So see to it that those who are feeling
little bit drowsy maybe you didn't sleep
well.
But we had a head call
that all of you slept for more than 4
hours at least. 4 5 6 hours.
All of you
should be
awake
and paying attention.
And
we'll do the techniques
inshallah how to keep people awake
tomorrow.
But now I'm giving a little bit you know
go and step wise little by little by
little.
Fine? So now this session
would be on the topic forms of Dawah.
What is the meaning of the word Dawah?
Dawah means to call.
It means to invite. In Islamic context
Dawah means inviting
the people towards Islam.
And specifically
when we use this word Dawah it means
inviting the non-Muslims towards Islam.
Giving them information about Islam.
Removing the misconceptions they have.
The other word used is Isla.
Isla in Arabic means
to correct.
It means to improve.
It means to rectify.
This word Isla
is more often used
when you are giving information to a
Muslim
giving him more knowledge of Islam.
Islam means to repair, to rectify
to improve.
So though this word Dawah is used
synonymously both
for the Muslims and non-Muslims, the
more appropriate word
when you are speaking to non-Muslims
giving them information of Islam or
calling them towards Islam, the
appropriate Arabic word is Dawah.
And when we speak to a Muslim
giving him more knowledge or rectifying
him or improving regarding Islam, the
more appropriate word is Isla.
As far as forms of Dawah is concerned
I personally have classified it into two
types. Every individual has its own way
of classification. In my experience I
have classified Dawah
into two different categories. One
is Dawah done directly live without any
media.
The second is Dawah
which is done indirectly through media.
Second type of Dawah did not exist
a few hundred years back.
At the time of the Prophet and the
Sahaba it didn't exist. But we can use
the rules of first category and
implement on second category and make it
effective.
This training program
is concentrating more on
the first category of Dawah.
Live
direct without a media.
Though in this training program because
we have incorporated stage three we
would be touching on the second category
also.
But all the trainings I did earlier did
not touch on the second category or
maybe just scratch the surface.
Now I'm thinking why did I keep 33 days?
I should have kept 50 days.
50 days means you have to stay here for
65 days.
Right or wrong?
Who would have come here if the training
program was for 50 days?
All except if the training program
instead of 33 days would have been for
50 days. That means you have to stay
here for 65 days. You would have come?
Again, now you understood.
Please
a Muslim?
No, behind you.
Brother Rahman, no?
Fine, sir.
Good. With that we have made a mistake.
I made a mistake I was afraid that
people
So next time inshallah if Allah wills I
don't know next time we'll be there or
not.
Anyway, now we can't extend because I've
got commitments after that.
But now I realize that if I had known
first I thought what will I add for 8
days? I did not have anything in mind.
I had vague ideas but
when we sat
Oh.
8 days is too less. I should have added
30 days. Then it became So we had a lot
of shuffling. Should we keep them? Then
we made we gave you the graph
yesterday.
So this training program inshallah would
include certain parts
of the second type of Dawah that is
indirect Dawah through media.
But this phase particularly the phase
one and phase two
is live Dawah
direct without a media.
In this session I'm only giving you
just some drops in the ocean or
scratching the surface about the second
type.
As far as
Dawah indirect through a media is
concerned it is classified under four
categories.
Dawah through print media
Dawah through audio media, Dawah through
video media, Dawah through electronic
media.
Now people may classify the way they
want. I prefer classifying in these four
categories.
Print media
audio media, video media and electronic
media.
As far as print media is concerned print
media further classified into periodical
and non-periodical media.
In the non-periodical media we have
booklets, we have pamphlets and
literature on
Islam and comparative religion or Dawah
whatever it is.
In the periodical media
we have media which is daily
for example newspapers.
We have media which is weekly.
We have media which is fortnightly.
We have print media which is monthly.
Which is quarterly every 3 months.
Which is bi-annually every 6 months. We
have media which is yearly. Different
variety.
Periodical media is media which is
regularly the same. It can continue in
parts.
That means you can say something knowing
very well that most probably the same
person you're addressing will read it in
the next issue. Whether it's daily,
whether it is weekly, whether it is
fortnightly, whether it's monthly,
whether it's quarterly, whether it's
bi-annually, whether it's annually.
You're in touch
with most of the people. In a
non-periodical media you address him
everything in one shot. There may be
volume two coming out. Who will read?
May read, may not read. Different. The
difference between a periodical and
non-periodical media. As far as print
media is concerned the specialty on
print media is a different ballgame
altogether.
The knowledge that is there for Dawah
may remain the same but the art
the technique of print media is a
specialty by itself. You normally you do
medicine.
That means you're doing general.
Little bit of physiology, little bit of
anatomy, surgery, medicine.
Then you pass your MBBS.
Then you may do your MD
or MS.
Master of medicine or master of surgery.
Then super specialty.
DM doctorate of medicine
or MCH master of surgery. You may become
after MBBS specialist of heart,
specialist of
brain, kidney.
Heart super specialty. Left ventricle,
only ventricle.
Oracle.
Super specialty.
Something like specialist super
specialty. So this is again field of
specialization.
In this
training program we will not be talking
anything about specialty of
print media. Though we have given you
many prints even that's an art. How to
make notes is an art.
That's a technique. It's coming in front
of you. You look oh.
What hard work went behind that? The
looks, the font.
What type it is? Bold, super bold,
Helvetica, Times Roman, school book. All
these all This may be German for some
and French for the others. Those who are
in the field of media know what
Helvetica what is Arial, what is bold,
what is non-bold, what is the point
size. You may have heard of it but
executing is different. You punch how it
should look presentable. So everything
is there. Now when I change the notes
it's a big ordeal. To add anything in
the note or get the whole copy. That's a
print media.
We won't be discussing that.
The second media
is the audio media.
In the audio media, but changing
the notes here have been
changed. Previously, when I did
the training program 16 and 1/2 years
back, we had audio cassettes.
Then we had
the audio CDs.
Now, audio cassette is obsolete.
Audio CDs, again obsolete.
Now, we have DVDs.
Audio DVDs.
We have got MP3.
Then we have smartphones.
Smartphone, everything audio. What do
you want? Previously, your Walkman
radio. Now, every smartphone is a
Walkman and everything.
Then you have without a phone also, iPod
you have got. Variety, you can.
The DAT is yet the digital audio tape,
which is one of the good forms. You can
store on hard disks.
The technology is changing.
At present, one of the high forms is
that digital audio tape and that is
getting obsolete. So, do you have the
LTO-6 for archiving, which is another
thing we'll discuss inshallah in the
video media.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Allah.